hey what's up youtube this is dr john
deloney with ramsay network
so i got a special video today and it's
a special request from a family member
they asked me to talk about the
psychology of
road rage not that they struggle with it
or anything
so let's set the stage you are in the
car and you are driving
you're going 75 miles down the highway
you're going five over the speed limit
because you're
one of these noble folks that only
cheats a little bit or
you're dropping off your little kid at
school you're waiting in that god-awful
soulless line of people waiting to
drop little timmy or little susie or a
little whoever off
in front of the school right and
somebody cuts you off and you
instantly wave at them with all but one
finger right you give them you give them
the bird
or you lay on the horn forever one of
those extended
horn honkers so annoying just
or you're in your little car or your
f-150 you think you're all
tough and somebody cut you off and you
zoom up behind them and you get this
close to them and you just follow them
around because you think that makes you
feel tough
in hardcore and i'll show them it's so
lame dude if they hit the brakes the
only person getting hurt in that deal is
your idiotic self but whatever or
somebody cuts you off
they cut in front of you right and you
grip your wheels
you clench your teeth how many of you
have kids that have learned
new words simply by being in the car
with you
while you drive or if you're in texas or
tennessee
and you're driving and somebody cut you
off and you just start thinking
i'm gonna get my gun right i'm a car
carrying whatever like we're not gonna
take it
anymore like seriously right so here's
the deal
if you're driving and somebody cuts you
off if you're going down the highway and
someone blows by at 100 miles
an hour if you're waiting in line at
sonic and somebody
scoots right in front of you and gets
into your parking spot you are suddenly
faced
with two cosmic truths
the first truth is that you are not the
center of the universe
and the second truth and this one hurts
you are in control
of basically nothing
when someone flies by you they cut you
off they cut in line
you feel small you feel lame you feel
out of control powerless you think
hey we have order around here and
there's rules and i was
next and i'm following all of the rules
right
you just feel small you feel slighted
you feel
less than you feel like hey there's a
set of rules and if we all played by the
same rules
then i would feel good about myself and
in these little moments at
75 miles an hour at 100 miles an hour or
three miles an hour in the chick-fil-a
parking lot
the cosmos rears its ugly head and you
realize that you have outsourced your
personal
spiritual and emotional validation this
idea of worthiness and dignity
to how other people think about you
you have outsourced the way you feel to
other people's behavior and this is
totally disorienting when you experience
it
it can unwind you instantly
and you realize that your human default
setting is not set to look for ways
people are
supporting you and caring for you and
putting good out in the world
you realize that you are actively
scanning your environment
all the time for yet another way you're
getting screwed
right and if you spend your time looking
for
places where people aren't being nice
where people aren't treating you the way
you think you should be treated where
people are
screwing you over you will always always
see it you'll always find it right and
so to remedy this disorientation
what do we do we get into their heads
and we decide
from the throne of our cars why they
just did what they did
psychologists call this fundamental
attribution error
that's us playing god that's us getting
inside somebody else's head
and deciding why they are driving so
fast deciding
why they just cut in line in front of us
at the child drop-off line or in the
fast food restaurant
and on the road it usually goes
something like this
i'm driving 75 miles an hour which is
just a little bit against the law
just five miles an hour over because i'm
a good person
i'm a moral person i like to help others
and i'm just better than most other
people and when somebody blows by you at
100 miles an hour
you get into their head and you think
you're driving fast
because you're evil and you suck and
you're a box of goat turds
you're the worst right you're deciding
while they're speeding
in this fundamental attribution era this
spending time in
other people's head is such a
waste of energy it's a waste of time
it's a waste of your soul it's
stupid and on its face it doesn't solve
anything
this remedy this blaming somebody else
this
acknowledging why somebody else is doing
something you're just deciding for them
it doesn't solve anything and then you
get to the truth
and the truth is no matter how much you
work out
no matter how many cool tough guy movies
you watch
no matter how many degrees you have how
smart you are how
safe you are how big your car is how
little your car is
all of it the truth is
you control very very
little almost nothing in fact
the only two things on planet earth that
you control
are your thoughts and your actions
that's it that's it
and when you're driving and somebody cut
you off
you are faced with that stark reality
instantly
david foster wallace talks about this
poetically
in his famous speech this is water it's
a graduation speech he gave to kenyon
college
if you haven't heard it as soon as this
video is over
google it it's incredible right but in
this speech he
calls out this critical idea that we get
to
choose what we think and i love it he
does a great job of explaining this
and so here's what i want you to do the
next time you're driving and somebody
cuts you off
they get too close to you they're
texting and driving
you can assume that they're a total butt
face
that they're the worst they're an idiot
right you can assume that or
you can choose to
put some positive energy out into the
universe to drop a quick
prayer you can assume man i bet he's
going to pick up his daughter from a
pretty dangerous situation hope he gets
there safely you can choose to think man
he may be on the way to the emergency
room
and he's got a sick kid in the back of
the car i hope they get there okay
you get to pick he's an idiot he's a
jerk he's a scumbag
or he's really got to get to wherever
he's going maybe he's just got rocket
diarrhea
and he doesn't want to get embarrassed
right let's give him that one
or maybe if a driver gets too close to
you and they flip you off
maybe they're coming from a hard work
conversation
they're about to lose their job they're
completely frazzled and they chose you
to take it out on
you get to decide whether you absorb it
and you say
i hope you have a better day man i must
i'm going to throw out a quick prayer
for you
or that you're gonna act like a
five-year-old you're gonna act like a
child if somebody flips you off in
traffic
just choose to let it go like a vapor
what's it actually doing to you you get
to choose to work towards making
empathy your default setting to choose
to thinking the best about people's
intentions and their behaviors
and not carrying around this spiky
poisonous baggage
of always assuming everybody's going
through their day trying to find ways
to make your life worse the reality is
most people aren't even thinking about
you work towards making
empathy your default setting not
victimhood
not frustration not anger you can be
right
or you can just choose to enjoy your
life
you can grip the steering wheel make
your blood pressure go up
grind your teeth down smash the
dashboard
that's kind of like punching yourself in
the face and hoping it breaks their nose
it doesn't change their life at all at
the end of the day road rage is dumb
stupid it's idiotic it solves nothing
it just makes your day worse
so choose joy choose laughter choose to
let it go
choose productive thoughts practice this
over time you will change your default
setting
to one of peace one of letting things
roll off
one of smiling wherever it is you go
choose to send people positive thoughts
choose to pray for somebody who cuts you
off
choose to give somebody the a-okay hope
things are okay
when they go flying by
they probably need the positive thoughts
too this is dr john deloney with ramsay
network
hit the subscribe button if you know of
road ragers or you know of people who
just do this
all day send this video to them
give them a like they need one right and
if you have any other questions if
you've got a special video you want me
to do
email me at ask john ramsey
solutions.com
have a great week be kind and i'll talk
to you soon